hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 7 book 7 of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics he discusses two
other states of a person's character
which are not virtue or vice but
correspond to those states that we call
self-control and lack of self-control
and it calls these softness and
endurance they really run in parallel to
self-control and lack of self-control
which in the strict sense you have to do
with pleasures them in fact with bodily
pleasures Aristotle says primarily the
pleasures of eating drinking or engaging
in you know various intoxicants like
like drinking alcohol gives us or the
pleasures of sex and he also you know
excludes some other pleasures from that
that we might want to put in here and
you'll see why in just just a minute so
he says that these are the same
qualities as self-control which is in
katia and lack of self-control ecclesia
but with respect to something different
instead of being about pleasures and not
being able to resist those pleasures it
has to do with pains
lubos and we should understand this term
pain in a very broad sense
just meaning physical pain like you know
what happens when you hit your thumb as
you're hammering a nail or you know
aches and pains that you have in your
body but there's a good reason to think
that Lupe can be in pain or disturbance
or something that you you know you find
upsetting in general and he says that
that's what these have to do with
softness and during softness is Malatya
endurance is comfort ana he uses these
down forms and verbal forms and
adjective forms to talk about people and
actions so he also says too that when
we're talking about deliberate avoidance
of pain where a person sort of reasons
it out says I just can't endure this
pink think for example of you know we
see this will happen in movies somebody
does something terrible to another
person and then they say look I just
can't go to jail right that could be an
example of softness in in a different
sense they say I'm not I'm not cut out
for this that what they're saying is I
can't endure the pains that I think I'm
going to encounter so I'm going to do
this course of action instead and
Aristotle says when it's done and that
sort of deliberate way then it's not
really like lack of self control and
self control or you know however we want
to translate them and Katya and
Achrafieh it's something more like in
temperance or you know the vice that
that it has to do with those sorts of
pleasures except now it has to do with
not being able to resist hangings we use
the Aristotle says the same term
softness for that kind of person but
it's really going beyond the Ken
softness that he's interested in what
he's primarily interested in he talked
about soft and he uses also another term
luxurious people people who are given
into luxury they don't resist pains that
most other people do so he's not
expecting some
superhuman quality right resisting every
gain whatsoever but he gives these
examples of somebody who has a cloak and
they just let it drag behind them
because they can't be bothered to pick
it up because that's that takes we might
say they don't they don't want to do
efforts they they don't like to have to
put up with something and I think
there's a good argument here to say that
perhaps the inability to deal well with
boredom in our own culture might be a
great example of the kind of softness
that Aristotle is talking about because
people do all sorts of goofy things and
fritter away a time and make bad
decisions based on their inability to
deal with something that you know is not
painful as such but is it is a kind of
analogous to pain feeling of boredom he
also talks about besides the person of
trails their cloak feigning sickness
pretending not to be well so that one
doesn't have to do something right to
get out of things these are the sorts of
things that I think are very easy for us
to relate to we actually start some TV
shows movies with premises about some
kid pretending to be sick why because he
doesn't want to go to school why because
there's something going on in school
that's going to be painful for him and
then quickly you know he or she realizes
that they've got run in the house and
that could be quite pleasurable but for
the most part it has to do with not
resisting pains your soul also says
something very interesting about what he
calls amusements you know things that we
do just to enjoy ourselves that are not
in themselves necessarily pleasurable
what would these include in our own
culture well playing games whether
they're board games or games like
throwing a ball with somebody else or
computer games those would be examples
of amusement binge watching Netflix or
Hulu or Amazon Prime or whatever you
want
they issue an arrow a long time that's
an example of an amusement sporting
events would be examples of amusements
what instead of doing something watching
other people to something right as a
matter of fact if we think about shows
lots and lots and lots of shows watching
people doing things where you sit on
your butt or you know laying on your
back or on your side just doing nothing
except watching other people things
those are the great extent plenty of
those they have games that you can go to
you go to the theater you could go
somewhere and listen to a poet read his
poetry or you know you do and go listen
to Lucinda he's read his history right
here in this look that sort of thing
people were back then so people who are
too fun aerosol is not saying don't it
don't enjoy anything right but people
who are too fun of amusements who made
that you know when they make decisions
they may make decisions in the right way
at the start but then they don't stick
to them because they like those
amusements too much they binge watch
despite their intention not to they go
to the party and they say okay we're
leaving at 10 o'clock and they're
closing the place down at two o'clock we
could go on and on and on with these
sorts of things he says amusement is a
kind of rest and dad is you know why
we're talking about lack of self-control
or the inability to resist pains because
he says the amusement is rest and
therefore slackening of effort addiction
to amusement is a form of excessive
slackness the term that he's he's using
therefore slackness is not an analysis
rest but on a houses you know leaving
off of something and it's painful to not
do that
so people are unable to not just resist
the pleasures that they want but they're
unable to stand up against the
hands that they might feel as a result
what would be the opposite of this sort
of softness that he's talking about here
well what Aristotle calls cartina
endurance is how we translate it but you
could say if the defines it as a sort of
resistance to pains and here's where
we're talking about the person who is
more resistant to pain than the other
they know the typical run-of-the-mill
person and it's not just that they don't
feel pain it's rather that they don't
allow pain to interfere with their
decision about what is right to do so
they have you know right reason they
have some sort of principle telling them
this is what you need to do and they
stick with it we might think of physical
pains you know what people do with their
doing as we say endurance training right
there boredom is also a factor besides
the physical pain that you feel in your
body cycling swimming but you know
running all those sorts of things I
suppose you could do jumping rope as
well putting up with that is you know
it's painful and we talk about a
runner's highs and stuff like that you
got to run a lot before you get her
under side walls of the time it doesn't
feel particularly good but if you stick
with it you you are able to do what it
is that you want to do become you know
somebody who's got some endurance my
weightlifting is like that too
it's painful in and of itself but
endurance can conceive you through that
what else would endurance be needed for
well that whole realm of amusements
being able to say no to oneself when you
want to just take it easy and not put in
a full day's at work and just hang
around and drink coffee and talk with
your co-workers or you know sit at home
and instead of doing the homework watch
some Netflix and spend the person who
has endurance stakes to it this is
something similar to what you know
people love this term these days
Ritt grid would include endurance in the
sense of hairstyles talking about that
is standing up the guest pains feeling
them but now allowing them to determine
what you do it so all of this is a
question of where one either gives into
or stands against the pains that might
interfere with doing what one knows or
at least feels is the right thing to do
in the situation